das vorgehen ist eigentlich immer das
gleiche die terroristische ziele in gaza
sind den israelischen behörden und
geheimdienste relativ umfangreich und
detailliert bekannt das heißt es gibt
für solche situationen wie sie sich
heute abend dort in dramatischer
geschwindigkeit entwickeln natürlich
vorbereitete pläne mit zielen die man
angreifen kann einerseits zur vergeltung
als klares zeichen aber andererseits
eben auch um die hamas-führung so unter
druck zu setzen und so quasi in ihrer
verstecke und bunker zu zwingen und von
kommunikation und entscheidung
abzuhalten dass man damit weitere
angriffe auf israel verhindern kann und
das ist das was jetzt gerade mutmaßlich
er in der residenz von benjamin
netanjahu in jerusalem mit dem engsten
kreis mit dem sogenannten
sicherheitskabinett national security
kabinett besprochen wird welche ziele
wollen wir in welchem umfang im gaza
jetzt angreifen wie gesagt erstens um
ein klares zeichen zu setzen um
vergeltung zu üben aber vor allem und
das ist viel wichtiger
um die struktur unter druck zu setzen
die kommandostruktur unter druck zu
setzen
die derzeit angriffe weitere angriffe
auf israel plant unvorbereitet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren